es el primer líder europeo que se reúne
con Petro Y además le hace la propuesta
de acoger los diálogos con el Ln de qué
dependerá entonces la sede de las
negociaciones
Bueno muy buenas noches tal cual como el
presidente petróleo manifestado esto
dependerá de las partes y creo que
digamos en este caso el lln tiene más
formas de poner condiciones sobre
precisamente Cuál será una de las sedes
Y en este momento al menos se ve difícil
que vaya a cambiar o a trasladarse y a
sacar un poco del escenario a desplazar
de nivel de importancia aquí
Y por qué la decisión de Sánchez de
empezar su gira Precisamente en Colombia
y habrá cambios en las relaciones de la
Unión Europea con el país ahora que está
gobernado por la izquierda
no sé si en su totalidad la Unión
Europea y precisamente si este tipo de
pronunciamientos y Esta visita oficial
es específicamente
representando a este país y no la unión
en su totalidad pero si la Unión Europea
va a jugar seguramente un rol
importantísimo en los posibles diálogos
con el elenco y ahora hablemos de la
propuesta de Petro le hizo a Estados
Unidos qué tan factible es que
Washington la acepte y en qué consiste
la política de negociación con los
narcotraficantes de la que habla el
presidente colombiano
bueno difícilmente yo creo que Estados
Unidos pese a tener en ese momento Un
gobierno demócrata y que puede ser un
poco más flexible tiene presiones
internas también y un poco con el
fracaso que se viene con la política de
radicación de cultivos Y esto no viene
solo no viene con unos cambios radicales
que se anuncian en estos últimos días
habrá que esperar Cuál es la posición de
Estados Unidos frente a esto pero no va
a ser nada fácil Especialmente cuando el
tema de la extradición se trata y
Estados Unidos pondría en tela de juicio
su relación con Colombia según esta
propuesta de Petro o no es posible
estamos más allá de que sea posible o no
no lo veo un escenario digamos tan
cercano que esto realmente lleve a un
proceso de lejanía o incluso rupturas de
las relaciones Colombia También necesita
en gran medida de Estados Unidos por
muchos temas de cooperación de recursos
Pero esto sí podría poner las relaciones
mucho más tensas y claramente a pesar de
que esto es una una decisión
discrecional Del estado colombiano va a
depender de lo que logre negociar con
Estados Unidos